[Music]
Priscilla Presley attending twin
granddaughters Harper and Finley's
Middle School graduation the twins oh
it's great it's great she makes an
appearance at the event but remains
separated from the rest of the family
seemingly indicating the dust hasn't
settled following the feud over who
should control the trust of her late
daughter and the twins mom Lisa Marie
her heart is broken Lisa we all love you
Priscilla was part of a months-long
battle with Harper and Finley's dad
Michael Lockwood and her granddaughter
actress Riley Keough over the estate it
is absolutely 100 mine always has been
mine Graceland always will be and when
it's no longer mine it would be my
children's but just last week they came
to an agreement Priscilla's lawyer
telling E.T all parties have reached a
settlement and the families are happy no
I think that's good and it's very
positive they are very excited for the
future Riley's lawyer echoed the
comments saying she's very happy and her
future is bright whatever happens
happens
after striking the deal Priscilla told
ET she was ready to move on confirming
all confusion has been resolved in
adding that she wants to make it clear
there was never any lawsuit fouled
against my beloved granddaughter Riley